not every sentient anomaly the scp
foundation contains is a monstrosity
hell-bent on destroying the world or a
dangerous apex predator with a taste for
d-class in fact most aren't most
sentient anomalies are perfectly docile
even polite they range from helpful
talking animals to self-aware ai to
former foundation personnel themselves
there's little need for these low
security anomalies to be treated with
the same paranoid caution reserved for
anomalies like scp-939
and
scp-049 and for some of them the
foundation can even help them out a
little bit one of these anomalies is
scp-4149
at cursory glance
scp-4149 seems to be some sort of
standard anomalous location not at all
uncommon for the foundation to deal with
just stick a lock on it and call it a
day right but the containment procedures
tell a different story mtf personnel are
ordered to act like they are visitors of
an art gallery when inside scp-4149
not just that but any character breaks
have to be played off like live theater
what kind of strange anomaly requires
hardened agents and researchers to act
like performance artists let's go back
to when the foundation first discovered
scp-4149
it was 2007 in chicago and foundation
agents across the city were stocking out
art galleries painting exhibitions
museums and other fine art repositories
it wasn't some wild goose chase to
finding a painting-based anomaly like
scp-1155 or scp-3864
but instead a concerted operation to
root out anomalies and people associated
with the notorious group of interest are
we cool yet don't let are we cool yet's
name fool you the foundation has a long
and storied history with this group of
subversive non-conformist artists that
sprang up after world war ii they've
changed over the years in political
attitudes and direction but one thing
remains consistent they make anomalous
art and not just anomalous art
dangerously anomalous art paintings that
drive people to madness sculptures that
kill viewers sound familiar and
installations that result in dozens of
casualties these anomalous art
terrorists are extremely dangerous and
no one knows them better than the
foundation chicago being known for its
art is one of their favorite haunts so
when the foundation launched a stakeout
operation tracking known are we cool yet
members they knew they'd find something
eventually that happened in june when
two foundation agents tailing a group of
are we cool yet members saw them moving
a number of paintings out of a truck and
into what seemed to be a regular
condominium the agents excited to
finally get a lead jumped out of the car
and quietly followed after them right
into the door of the building they
rushed in with their guns to find
nothing but on the second floor
things were more interesting one of the
are we cool yet members was laying on
the ground writhing in pain and covering
his face upon being poked by one of the
agents he lowered his hands revealing a
gory sight the man's face was warped
like a picasso painting his nose was on
his forehead his mouth was slanted all
the way to the left of his face and his
eyes were on his tongue he cries that
the gallery did this to him and that his
friend ran in the agents turn into the
bedroom instead of a wall and a window a
large hallway leading into a space that
doesn't exist outside the building is
present
scp-4149 the last thing the agents see
before calling for backup another are we
cool yet member shaking hands with what
appears to be a gigantic sloth in a
three-piece suit by the time the mtf
arrived with special anti-cognito hazard
gear they were all ready to enter
scp-4149
the four-man team enters rounding a
corner into what appears to be a
makeshift art gallery filled with
anthropomorphic animals lizards in
loungewear birds and fancy dresses and
the large sloth in a suit the agents had
seen along the walls are paintings and
artworks blurred by the agent's special
eyewear it doesn't take long before the
team are noticed by the animals
scp-4149 instances who start criticizing
their acting in english to the mtf's
surprise the heavily armed men start
hearing complaints in incompetent social
commentary about their lack of subtlety
from a growing crowd of clothed giant
animals confused they are eventually
rescued by the sloth who plays off their
strange arrival as a performance piece
gone awry and dismisses the crowd to
other art pieces after very slowly
dragging them into a corner the bested
sloth politely introduces himself as
professor zorkanov the owner of this art
gallery he claims to be a man of culture
and enjoyer of fine art who found he
could only truly operate his gallery how
he wanted free of the bounds of any one
world in fact the entirety of
scp-4149 exists in its own pocket
dimension upon being asked he explained
that the are we cool yet member was
trying to sell him some work but it
wasn't refined enough for the
professor's tastes but the artist seemed
to have run off to another planet to
train specifically one lacking an
atmosphere the professor agrees to be
designated as
scp-4149-2 and undergo interviewing to
help the foundation understand what the
situation surrounding his gallery is
which is where the foundation finds most
of their information for the anomalies
description
scp-4149 is what's known as an
extra-dimensional space a location that
doesn't quite exist in any one reality
but by itself in a pocket dimension it's
accessible through a hallway in the
apartment building which the foundation
has bought and slated for demolition
inside
scp-4149 one can access a large
warehouse serving as a gallery
containing upwards of 70 different art
pieces ranging from fancy oil paintings
to contemporary sculptures and modern
art almost all of them are cognito
hazardous in one way or another
extremely dangerous to the untrained
human mind the gallery itself seems to
be populated by a wide variety of
entities not just the finely dressed
animals that caught the mtf off guard
they claim to come from all the various
neighboring universes and realities that
scp-4149 borders and seemed to be fine
looking at all of the arc pieces and of
course the proprietor of the
establishment scp-4149-2
professor zorkonov 2 meters tall dressed
in a nice waistcoat and tweed jacket
foundation agents all describe him as
friendly and polite to a fault even if
he is a giant sloth unfortunately that
means everything he says or does is at a
snail's pace or more accurately a sloth
space but he usually spends his time
plodding between the various art pieces
and explaining or discussing them with
the guests as curator of the gallery
where the professor gets the artworks
isn't quite clear nor is how he says he
can travel through universes and worlds
to some degree but this is unconfirmed
for now all the foundation knows is that
sometimes the works in
scp-4149 just suddenly seem to cycle out
with new attractions the gallery isn't a
perfect socializing space though the
entry that exists in the apartment
building is a design flaw a construction
error but not one that can be easily
fixed without tearing the entire place
down and starting again something the
professor has sounded very upset at when
someone deciphered his glacial yelling
scp-4149 is friendly to foundation
interests though the professor doesn't
want uninvited guests to know about his
gallery any more than the foundation
does to that end he's cut a deal so long
as
scp-4149 submits to background
interviews and
scp-4149 is carefully kept under
containment
scp-4149-2 will be permitted to keep
operating his gallery and the foundation
will protect it against hostile
intruders what intruders you ask well
you'll have to look to the interviews
for that the main interview is conducted
by a d-class through an earpiece the
giant sloth statement have to be sped up
multiple times to be understandable on
the recording it starts off simple
zorkanov is the best human approximation
to the professor's real name him coming
from another world presumably one
inhabited by other sloths his name
wasn't designed to be spoken by simple
humans but he explains the universe that
scp-4149 exists in is a shell a universe
that has undergone heat death and become
completely empty before being compacted
into just enough space to build scp-4149
the professor having some ability to pop
from universe to universe decided to
make this place his home and host to his
love of art and expression he seems
reluctant to talk about his original
home though until directly asked by the
d-class
then he explains he was a man in well
standing in his home universe on a world
inhabited by creatures similar to
himself he enjoyed all the fruits of
society culture music social occurrences
and yes art unfortunately the rest of
his society didn't share his views on
art they considered it not only a waste
of time but an insult an offensive level
of arrogance being a highly
technological society they thought art
and humanities were inappropriate
expressions of emotion but from the
professor's point of view all this had
done was create a deeply unhappy deeply
uneducated society his private art
collection in his manner was a closely
guarded secret but eventually the secret
got out his name was spat out as a
cultural extremist a subversive
non-conformist who was giving dangerous
ideas to the next generation a mob
formed and did what mobs do best they
chased him from his home at night and
burned his collection barely escaping
with his life and the few pieces of art
he could grab the professor swore to
rebuild his collection for the joy of
all as the interview continues the
d-class reveals he is blind that's how
he avoided being driven insane by any of
the many cognito hazardous art pieces
the professor hasn't heard of blindness
before but sympathizes eventually things
settle into a familiar rhythm professor
zorkanov continues to operate his
gallery for the pleasure of all of his
visitors and the foundation need only
station one armed guard in the apartment
instead of spending time money and
effort forcing everyone into
inconvenient containment in the middle
of a crowded city but just a few short
months later the foundation receives a
call from the agent on duty requesting
backup once again the mtf arrived on
scene kitted out for cognito hazards
they enter into
scp-4149 heavily armed and armored this
time they find something much more
surprising and dangerous than an art
exhibition the guests are lurking around
the edges of the walls but the professor
is in the middle of the floor arguing
extremely slowly with two more giant
sloths they're dressed in tactical
combat gear and holding what looked to
be guns their yelling sped up is made
clear the newcomers are berating the
professor for expressing his art and for
running from something called the
xenarthra council when they finally
notice the presence of the mtf they
scoff and gradually raise their weapons
telling the mtf to leave while they
still have the chance but while one of
them is busy yelling at the sloths to
drop their weapons another one of the
troops simply walks over and pulls the
guns out of the clawed paws of the
sloths come on they're sloths man by the
time they slowly realize their weapons
are no longer in their hands the sloths
panic at the thought of these strange
furless creatures moving so many times
faster than they ever thought possible
just before they're handcuffed the pair
disappear in a burst of green light and
at this all the guests burst into
applause this conflict this emotion this
humor
this is the performance they were
waiting for the whole time now check out
killer living graffiti
scp-1155 predatory street art or scp-683
refrigerator art for more art-related
anomalies that will blow your mind